c'était délicieux j'ai quand même vous
raconter une petite anecdote qu'il m'est
arrivé avec monsieur était au bout là
bas l'acteur dont chaque tour il y
aurait un temps où je tournais à paris
en été avec jean gabin et tous les soirs
ont dîné ici parce qu'il n'y avait pas
grand monde et ondine est là après le
tournage aucune machos les soirs elles
étaient déboutées magnifique et un soir
on était en train de miner tous les deux
et qui est ce qu'on voit arriver
monsieur oublier kinois et ensuite tu la
devine on s'assoit tous les trois la
même table et on commence à manger et à
cette époque là j'aime autant dire
qu'elle tenait mieux à faire qu'à cheval
tous les trois c'était sérieux et
évidemment de quoi par lyon nous en
mangeant entre intellectuels doigt ce
que ça donnait on a commencé par des
recettes de cuisine et patati et patata
et des adresses et à la fin du repas et
et dieu sait si j'étais enfin celui ci
dit je viens de découvrir une ambiance
fabuleuse un bon fait vieux et c'est
quoi l'autre avait les larmes aux yeux
en parle il était comme ça ils n'en
pouvaient plus d'être
bien trop tôt et c'était attendu et
c'est accepter le blâme et on peignait
ce pot-au-feu toi bon je vais raccourcir
l'histoire je te donne ma parole
d'honneur à temps il nous a sauvés
je le reste voilà ils se sont levés de
table et il a le langage ans a dit on y
va
j'ai dit ça c'est pas possible on va
demain on va vous rendra d or à cannes
et je leur ai sauvé la vie car à 11
heures du soir on prend la voiture
photo foule à la gare à la gare du nord
[Rires]